[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم شكرا لكم اسود الاطلس نجوم
المغرب منتخب الساجدين المرضيين فما
انجزتموه حتى مبلغ نصف النهائي غير مسبوق
لقد منحتم بادائكم الرياضي والاخلاقي
جماهيركم حول العالم العربي والاسلامي
وافريقيا اوقات سعيده واحلام متقدمه في
كره القدم التي هو منذ زمن بعيد تخطى
تاثيرها الملاعب الخضراء لتكون بعدا
تنافسيا عالميا على رفرفه الاعلام
شكرا لكم اسود الاطلس من فلسطين التي لم
تنسوا علمها وشكرا لكم من قطر التي اضفتم
الى مونديال ها اللؤلؤي حماسا عربيا نادرا
وفخرا بتتويج نجمه الخضراء ضمن مجموعه
الاوائل وهي مرتبه صار من الصعب رؤيتكم
دونها فرهان عليكم كبير والايام القادمه
سير وعين الله ترعاه الى العناوين
بعد المانيا فرنسا ترفع القبعه لقطر على
نجاح مونديال 2022
قناه المانيه تصنف بالطائفيه تقارن بين
لاعبي المغرب وداعش بسبب السبابه
منتخب المرضيين لقب جديد يضاف الى القاب
المنتخب المغربي
جنود اسرائيليون شاركوا في مذبحه الطنطوره
يتذكرونها بضحكه عريضه
استفيدوا من عروضي بوتن النوويه قبل نفاذ
الوقت والصبر
المرزوقي كنا مفخره وصرنا مسخره وسعيد يرد
على المطالبين برحيله فليرحلوهم
[موسيقى]
مرحبا ان تاتي يا متاخرا خيرا من الا تاتي
ابدا مثلا فرنسي استذكره الفرنسيون ولو
متاخرين فبعد المانيا فرنسا تهنئ قطر
بالمونديال وتشيده وزيره الرياضه الفرنسيه
املي اودي كاستيره بالنجاح الباهر في
تنظيم كاس العالم وتدعو الجميع الى رفع
القبعه لقطر
انه علينا ان نرفع القبعه لهذا البلد على
الطريقه التي نظم بها هذا الحدث العالمي
لن ننسى كلمات الامير عندما قال مرحبا
بالجميع كاس العالم تلعب دون حدوث اي
مشاكل كبيره نحيي قطر على نجاحها في تنظيم
كاس العالم وتقديمها بشكل رائع حتى الان
خلوا القبه على راسكم بس خلوا براسكم ان
الناس سواسيه وان اسوا انواع الافتراء هو
الذي يصدر عن المرتكبين الذين يحاولون
تغطيه عوراتهم بالصاقها بالاخرين صحيفه
فضيحه مدويه حول استغلال عمال اجانب لا
يملكون او اقامه ولا عقود عمل في المشاريع
المخصصه لاولمبياد باريس 2024 وقالت لبراس
وفي تحقيق هؤلاء العمال يقومون باعمال شقه
ولا يحضرون باي ضمان اجتماعي وقانوني
ويتقادون مبالغ زهيده دون الاستفاده من اي
يوم عطله
عندما اكلت لحوم المسلمين على يد
الصليبيين معره النعمان تاريخ لا ينسى تحت
هذا العنوان بث التلفزيون التركي تقريرا
هذا الاسبوع ذكر انه استجابه لحمله اطلقها
الباب ايربان الثاني عام 1095
انطلقت جيوش الحمله الصليبيه الاولى
لاحتلال بيت المقدس واكنافه واخضاع
المسلمين في بلاد المشرق الاسلامي
والسيطره عليها حاصر الصليبيون مدينه معره
النعمان السوريه لعده اسابيع القوه غير
متكافئه بتاتا فيتفاوض اهل المعره مع
الصليبيين الذين تعاهدوا لهم بالامان
والحمايه مقابل الاستسلامهم لكن النتيجه
كانت فضيعه يمكث الصليبيون بعهدهم ويذبحون
كل المسلمين الذين يجدونهم امامهم فيقتل
لهفه الابرياء
ويوفق المؤرخون فرنسيون رافقوا الحملات
الصليبيه اكل الجنود الصليبيين لحوم
الاطفال والرجال بعد شويها كل ذلك كان يتم
تحت رايه الصليب التي تحملها الاعلام
والدروع وشعيره التصليب على الصدور فهل
لاحد من المسلمين ان يربط اليوم بين شعيره
التصليب الدينيه المسيحيه والحملات
الصليبيه الاجراميه الدمويه بالطبع كلا
ولا ينبغي ذلك لعقل منصب فليست الحملات
الصليبيه
وانقاذها البابايات والكنيسه ليست اختصارا
للامه المسيحيه وتعاليمها
فكيف توصلت قناه فلت الالمانيه بحقد متبل
بالجهل منكه بالسذاجه الى المقارنه بين
لاعبي المنتخب المغربي
والتنظيم الدوله داعش بسبب انتشار صوره
لنجوم المغرب يرفعون فيها اصبع السبابه
الذي يرفعه نحو مليارين مسلم كل يوم سيزول
العجب عندما نعرف ان قناه فلتر المديه هذه
تسخر بثها لدعم اسرائيل ولي العداء
للاسلام ومن حسن حظ المسلمين ان كثيرا من
اعلام الغرب المعادي لهم يتكلم دون ان
يقرا ويقرا دون ان يفهم تعبان فوزي
مش اشتاق
فوزيه
ونطلع مشكله
هذه المشاهد وغيرها لرجال امني مونديال
قطر وهم يؤدون الصلاه جماعه حدث عادي
طبيعي يتكرر ملايين المرات يوميا على
امتداد العالم الاسلامي انها فريضه تؤدى
وليست فرضيه تستعرض لكن بعض المختلين عفوا
المختلفين يعتبرون ان قطر تحاول استغلال
الدين
واسلمت الرياضه
[موسيقى]
ولا بيع عن ذكر الله وابطال الصلاه نجم
منتخب المغرب ولاعب باريس سان جيرمان اشرف
حكيمي يفتخر بوالديه وبالوالدين احسانا
فهو سبق ان كشف بنفسه لصحيفه
الايطاليه ان والده كان بائعا متجولا
بسيطا في السوق ووالدته عملت في تنظيف
المنازل بشرف يقول اشرف انا فخور جدا
بالتضحيات الكبيره التي بذلاها من اجل
احضار خبز ايامنا الى المائده منتخب
المرضيين لقب جديد يضاف الى القاب منتخب
اسود الاطلس الذين جسدوا في الملاعب صوره
الاسره المتلاحمه وموقع الام السامي فيها
لجوء اللاعبين اولا الى احضان امهاتهم هذه
المشاهد وصفها الناس على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ببر الوالدين
اي يسجد اللاعب لخالقه كردي فعل فوريا بعد
فوز رياضي فذلك تصرف ايماني تلقائيا جميل
ولا احد يقول ان اللعبه فتح للقدس او
الاندلس كما يردد بعض المنتقدين
[موسيقى]
شعب اندونيسيا كما شاهدنا كان يشجع منتخب
المغربي بالصلاه على النبي محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم وهو يعلم ان كره القدم لن تعيد
امجاد الامه لكنه تعبير عن الحبل الرابط
والعاصم لهذه الامه والا ما الذي جمع
العربيه والاعجمي على تشجيع الشعب المغربي
الذي وصل الى اجتماعات نواب في البرلمان
التركي
[تصفيق]
انها امه واحده في حقيقه الوجود لا يصنعها
الاعلام ولا يستطيع ان يلغيها ثم ياتينا
كاتب فرنسيون يهودي من اصول جزائريه ينكر
على المنتخب المغربي رفع علم فلسطين
ويطالب المغرب ملكا او حكومه بالاعتذار عن
ذلك كي نؤمن فعلا بصداقه المغرب في
الاتفاقيه مع اسرائيل يقول
وهل في الاتفاقيه بند سري يلغي الاعتراف
بفلسطين وعلمي فلسطين
مجزره ضد اهالي قريه الطنطوره عمى 48 تشبه
الى حد بعيد مجزره حي التضامن بدمشق التي
ارتكبها جنود النظام السوري عام 2013
الفيلم الذي اخرجه الاسرائيلي ال شبارتس
يستعرض ما جرى في الطنطوره قريه الصيادين
الوادعه على الساحل الفلسطيني حيث وفق
شهادات حيه لجنود في لواء اسكندرون
الصهيوني اعترفوا بارتكاب عمليات قتل
بالجمله عام
1948 ضد اهالي القريه وشهدات اخرى لنادين
من المذبحه ومن ذلك تبيان كيف حصلت القريه
يوم 22 من ايار عام 48 من البحر ومن
الجهات الثلاث وكيف تم قصفها من قبل
طائرتين بريطانيتين قبل مداهمتها وانتهاك
كل ما فيها اذ تم علاها للعزله بعد اسرهم
واطلاق الرصاص عليهم دون واسع او رابع
عندما تشاهد فيلم عن محرق النازيه باليهود
لا تستطيع الا ان تتعاطف مع الضحايا اذا
كنت ذا فطره بشريه سليمه
فلماذا يستذكر جدود اسرائيل مجاذرهم
بالضحايا الفلسطينيين فيضحكون
نتعاطفوا معه لوكوست كوم فتسخرون منه
لوكوستنا مع انها من صنعكم
يعلقوا ناشط فلسطين
خروج مشاهدات مذبحه الطنطوره الى العلم
تزامنت مع قتل جيش الاحتلال الطفله
الفلسطينيه جنا زكارنه برصاصه قناص
استهدفها وهي على سطح منزلها اثناء اقتحام
لجنين ليعلم العالم ما هي اسرائيل التي
صدمت ايضا بحسب مواقع فلسطينيه شقيقه
الشهيد عطا زكارنه بمدينه جنين كان يسحب
جثمانه من الارض ولا يعلم انه اخوه
رش عن البعاد لما
راحت ما في اتحمل بعد فكرت متاك زعيم وحزب
المانعه اليهوديه المتطرف بين كبير يدعو
لطرد مراسلي شبكه الجزيره بعد رفعها دعبا
قضائيه ضد اسرائيل في جريمه اغتيال شيرين
ابو عقله امام المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
وزير الماليه ابيج دور ليبرمن الذي كان
مبدعا في التطرف لم يعد امامه بوجودي بين
كبير الا ان يتراجع خطوه الى الوراء
وينسخ مواقفه ويتمناها مؤخرا اتهمت جمعيه
يهوديه الباديه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
المنتهيه ولايته يا اير لابيد بارتكاب
جرائم حرب ابان العدوان الاخير على غزه
الصيف الماضي مجرم الحرب هذا لبيد لا
يستطيع تحمل حجم الارهاب الجديد مع ثمار
بنك فير فيصفه بالمجرم وهو صادق ويبشر
لابيد بان اسرائيل ستصبح دوله من العالم
الثالث مع هؤلاء المتطرفين فيما يعترض
بهيج على تصنيف اسرائيل بانها دوله قبل
وضعها ضمن عالم ثالث او تاسع بن كثير مجرم
عنيف يستمر بدعم الارهاب ولم يخدم يوما
واحدا في الجيش الحكومه التي يجري تشكيلها
الان ليست حكومه لكود وليست حكومه يمين
انها اكثر الحكومات تتطرفا وجنونا في
تاريخنا اسرائيل والامارات تصادقان على
اتفاقيه الشراكه الاقتصاديه الشامله
والوزير الاماراتي ثاني زيودي يبشر بزياده
لافته للتجاره البينيه بين ابو ظبي وتل
ابيب واشاره الوزير الاماراتي الى ان
التجاره غير النفطيه بين بلاده واسرائيل
زادت بنسبه 114% في الاشهر تسعه الاولى من
جاري
[موسيقى]
يحرص الرئيس الروسي على التاكيد دائما
ومنذ عده سنوات بان استراتيجيته النوويه
دفاعيه ان ضربتم ضربنا وهو كررها متعده
ايام في معرض تاكيده ازدياده خطر نشوب حرب
النوويه
لكنه بعد يومين على هذا الكلام لفت الى ان
عرضه بالاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه ليس ابديا
وقد يكون لمده محدوده فقال ان موسكو تفكر
رسميا اوقات تفكر باضافه امكانيه توجيه
الضربه النوويه الوقائيه الاولى الى
عقيدتها العسكريه فعلى الغرب اي يستفيد من
عروض بوتين الحاليه قبل نفاذ البضائع
والصبر
شطورتك اروج
بكروبتك نسيبها مو قطيتنا ستريشنا
في الحزب الهندسيه المتشدد الحاكم في
الهند يتراسون حفله قسما بمقدساتهم على
مقاطعه المسلمين في بلادهم
فلماذا لا يقاطعون المسلمين خارج الهند في
طريقهم في الخليج مثلا في كثير نفر معلوم
مدير زعماء من حزبراتيه جنه الحاكم يرددون
قسما بمواصله مقاطعه المسلمين في الوظائف
في العمل وفي السكن وانهم لم يعطوا قرشا
واحدا لمتاجر المسلمين
[موسيقى]
بعد هو شيء يكون فم اصلاحات اعطيني الرئيس
بشار الاسد
لا تتحسن بعد ان يزورها الرئيس ورغم ذلك
يواصل حاكم قرطاج قيس سعيد تفقد احوال
الرعيه وسط كتيبه مدججه من الحراس الامنيه
مواطن تونسي لم يرفع سقف مطالبه يستحلفه
بالله علبه حليب فقط يريد علبه حليب عم
تسمعي يا حبيبي
ان شاء الله
سحليه زحليب كهرباء ما نحط شيء
الرئيس التونسي الاسبق المنصف المرزوقي
يستخدم السجع لشرح الوضع كنا مفخرا وصلنا
مسخره
والمذيع خاف من ان يكمل المرزوق المصطلحات
المناسبه سجيا مسخره
الى حاله تونس المسخره تونس المبخره كانت
مفخره الدستور 2014
حقيقي وضعه ان هو بالشعب واا تم النقاش في
مطولا ثم شفت الدستور بتاعت 2022 اللي هو
كان فعلا الدستور مسخره فرضا باغلاطه كده
في تحدي قاسم جدا من متظاهرين تونسيين
علينا نحن في الاعلام الناقد او الساخر
خرج التظاهرات في تونس لا ترحم برامجنا
تحت عنوان ارحل ايها الرئيس قيس سعيد في
اي نكبه ستعصف ببرامجنا لو رحل
قيس العابدين الى الشارع تعود جبهه الخلاص
المعارضه هذه المره تطالب برحيل الرئيس
سعيد على طريقته الفرمانيه رد الرئيس سعيد
على المطالبات برحيله بان عليهم هم ان
يرحلوا ويتوارا
الوجه
هو احمد الحسناوي صاحب العباره الايقونه
التي رافقت ثورات الربيع العربي
هذه اللحظه التاريخيه يبدو ان اينشتاين
استطاع اخيرا ان يقنع خليفه حفتر بان
الغباء هو فعل نفس الشيء مرتين بنفس
الاسلوب والخطوات وانتظار نتائج مختلفه
حفتر فعلها اكثر من مرتين وثلاثه محاوله
اسقاط طرابلس فاسلم اخيرا ساعات الصفر
خاصه الى الزمن وانتقل للتلويح بالانفصال
عن العاصمه طرابلس
والسيطره على مناطق النفط الشرقيه
[موسيقى]
في العاصمه على ما هو عليه
قد يدفعهم الى الاتحاد يقرا عليهم الحاسم
باداره شؤونهم
وبناء مؤسساتهم
وتوظيفي مواردهم الطبيعيه لصالحهم في
سوريا
الى الرئيس بشار الاسد فاساء الى رب
العالمين
سبحانه وتعالى
[موسيقى]
بتحبوا مشكلتك
المشهد التالي عنوان اطيب الناس فماذا
تختارون انتم تلميذ سوريون مهجرا فقير
يعمل بعد دوام المدرسه في تنظيف السيارات
جاء اثناء العمل فحصل على شطيره يسد بها
رمقه لكنه فوجي بضيف حضر بلا دعوه قطه
جائعه هي الاخرى فهل يطردها هذا الطفل
الكريم لنرى شو عم تعمل قطه
ليش احسن منك
[موسيقى]
شو بيشتغل
القهوه طيب ليش قاعده على الارض هو برد
عليك على الارض
اه
اخيرا عارضات الازياء يعاملنا في العراق
معامله السفراء ولا ندري سفراء من ولما
الجواز الدبلوماسي العراقي اصبح موجود في
حقائب معظم العارضات
ازياء ومشاهير في تطبيق تيك توك على جواز
سفر دبلوماسي مؤكدين مخاطبه وزاره
الخارجيه لتوضيح اليه من حيث الجوازات
[موسيقى]
ختاما عندما حرر صلاح الدين الايوبي بيت
المقدس كان ربع جيشه العظيم من المقاتلين
المغاربه الذين ارادوا بعض الانتصار
العوده الى اوطانهم كغيرهم من المتطوعين
من بلاد الشام والعراق ومصر واخرين الا ان
السلطانه صلاح الدين سمح للجميع بالعوده
الا المغاربه وحين سئل عن سبب تمسكه بهم
وبناء حي مقدسي خاص بهم اجاب بان المغاربه
قوم يعملون في البحر ويفتكون في البر
اشداء على الكفار لا يخافون طرفه عين في
الدفاع عن المقدسات والمسلمين يختم صلاح
الدين
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
من الفحيح
شعب الجبارين الاسطوره بدعيلك
يامغربنا هالله هالله هالله هالله يالله
رايكم
[موسيقى]
حره عربيه الله الله يا ابن المغرب بنحبك
شعبنا بحيي شعبك احنا معك احنا جنبك دايما
على طول
[موسيقى]